may 5 is not
independence day mexicans celebrate their
independence day from spain on
september 16 may 5 was the battle of
puebla where a small
mexican army won a battle against a
french army in 1862 on may 5  may
is not considered a national holiday
although if it is celebrated in town according to the
consul of distilled alcohols the sale
of tequila more than doubled
in 2011 and 2012 the
california avocado commission estimates that in
2013 americans consumed more
or less 87.3 million pounds of
avocado one of the largest celebrations
of the 5th of may is in the city of
los angeles california
in 2010 the festival covered more than 24
blocks of downtown los angeles an
annual race of chihuahuas that is
taken to  cape in tracksuit arizona at the end
of the celebrations a king and queen
are crowned